this video is about weird and terrifying
animals
but you know what the weirdest animal is
us we love to be afraid
no other animal does this you don't see
gazelles on the serengeti dressing up as
cheetahs for a hoot
and there are well studied psychological
reasons why humans enjoy being
frightened
and we have a video coming up all about
fear and phobias so
hit all the stuff to make sure you don't
miss it it's going to be our weirdest
video yet you know what's weird your
skin tone what now
what shade of orange is that it's self
tanner tan
who you kidding that's orange i'm trying
to do a thing here you look like a new
inmate at a prison where they ate
nothing but carrots
i don't know what that means yeah you do
now we indulge in all kinds of different
ways to scare each other
one of our favorite ways monsters
werewolves zombies
chupacabra bigfoot the loch ness monster
we get a satisfyingly fun
chill when we hear stories about these
creatures now bigfoot and the loch ness
monster aren't real
or are they but here are 10
terrifying animals that actually exist
but i really wish they didn't
and here's an appetizer
that's a lizard squirting poisonous
blood from its eyeballs
what why and that's what we call a
segway folks
welcome to the y files where smart folks
like us get together to talk dirty
now if you've got a high iq and a good
sense of humor hit the like and
subscribe buttons and that helps keep
the content flowing like the sea of
galilee what now amen brother
today's topic is terrifying animals now
the earth is about four and a half
billion years old when the earth was
young it was much hotter
no who wasn't you're telling me but as
the earth cooled
water emerged it didn't take long for
organic compounds to get together in a
process called
abiogenesis boom life
when life began over 3 billion years ago
it was a single cell
today there are over 9 million
identified species of animals
that doesn't even count plants or
anything besides plants and animals
now that's a lot but according to
nature.com there's so much biodiversity
that over 90 percent of animals are yet
to be discovered
and it could take another thousand years
to catalog them all some animal species
are awesome
puppies kittens bacon but some are
absolutely terrifying hecklefish how
about you read the names
i'll fire off a few facts let's do it
number one giant horned lizard the giant
horned lizard or the regal horned lizard
is
3 ounces of pure terror 85 grams his
strike speed is over 22 miles an hour 35
kph
that's twice as fast as a rattlesnake it
can grab prey 5 inches away 13
centimeters
in 30 milliseconds now it takes 100
milliseconds for you to blink
so in that time he can snatch two ants
and choke down a whole cricket
now this thing is not just fast it's
strong if you scale up a horned lizard
to the size of a full-grown bull and
they go head-to-head
the bull is hamburger given its body to
weight ratio
this horned lizard at that scale would
yield 14
000 pounds of force a full-grown bull
only six thousand but what makes this
guy terrifying
is his unique defense mechanism
weaponized eyeballs
when threatened by a predator it builds
up pockets of blood in its eye sockets
and it could shoot a stream almost six
feet
accurately and its squirt force is more
than twice that of a fire truck
a scientific term oh by the way the
blood
it's toxic yeah the lizard's main diet
is poisonous harvester ants
it's immune to the venom but it stores
the venom and deploys it in that
bloodstream like a bio weapon
and if that blood hits a predator in the
mouth or the eyes
it's going to be in pain it's going to
be sick it's not going to mess with the
lizard again
[Music]
giant isopod a woodlouse or a pill bug
is about one centimeter long and they're
found all over the world
but what happens when you scale one of
those up 40 times
and throw it in the ocean you got
yourself a giant isopod
giant iso pods are deep sea scavengers
that scoot around the ocean floor
pretty much eating anything they can
find basically a roomba of the sea
not everyone is terrified of giant
isopods in some parts of asia they eat
them
they do and if you want to see that
although i don't know why you would
i will link to some videos of folks
cooking and eating giant isopods in the
description below
star-nosed mule ah sorry
star knows mole the star knows mole is
one of canada's most bizarre species
more bizarre than canadians be nice that
thing looks like its face exploded into
two anuses
it does with hemorrhoids that
stuff is actually its nose and it's
covered in about 25
000 sense receptors known as elmer's
organs
quiet its sense of smell is so acute
that it can detect odor boy i'm glad i
can't do that
i bet it's like a sewer in here i
understand i swim in my own waste you
know
it's time to clean your bowl i get it
thank you the star knows mole is the
world's fastest eating mammal the time
it takes for it to
find hunt catch and devour its prey is
less than a quarter of a second
its main diet is earthworms but that
doesn't make it any less terrifying
amazonian giant centipede scolopendra
gigantia is one of the world's largest
centipedes found throughout south
america this aggressive predator will
eat anything it can overpower
animals 10 to 15 times its size insects
spiders no problem but this thing will
also go after
mice bats even birds if you can catch
them not terrified yet
but the centipede it's also venomous oh
boy can it kill people
it can at least one human death has been
attributed to its bite
it was found hiding inside a soda can
[Music]
cyclops shock a shark should have two
eyes
that's it that's it well this one's a
bit of a curveball because
this cyclops shark was real but it's not
technically a species a shark fisherman
found it inside a pregnant shark
when you say found do you mean cut it
out of the belly
i'm gonna be sick scientists have
speculated that this shark fetus was
suffering from cyclopia
meaning having one eye cyclopia is a
birth disorder that actually affects one
in sixteen thousand animal births
including humans rarely does an animal
born with cyclopia survive birth
but sometimes like with this calf born
last year in india
they do make it
terrifying goblin shock
the goblin shark is a rare species of
deep sea shark whose lineage goes back
125 million years
its jaws are not connected to its skull
so it can kind of
shoot out its teeth like a second face
it has the fastest jaws in the ocean so
fast you can only see it in slow motion
what terrifies me is that face which is
how it got its name
it looks like someone haphazardly
slapped a human mouth on a fish and
called it good
hey seems okay to me
[Music]
number seven horror frog what if you
crossed a werewolf with a poisonous frog
i don't recommend it you'd end up with a
horror frog or sometimes called the
hairy frog
now if you came across one of these you
don't want to touch it gerald durrell
was a famous tv host and naturalist who
learned this the hard way when this frog
is grabbed or attacked
it breaks its own toes and forces the
sharp bones
through its skin to create claws
and that skin it regenerates oh yes it's
also been called the wolverine frog
i'd like to buy this man to drink it
even starts out dangerous
its tadpoles are muscular carnivorous
and features
several rows of teeth terrifying from
day one
wait wait wait wait wait why are you
showing this this is a trader chirwana
of celti
i thought you called it little mr happy
it's an amphibian found in south america
oh i thought now's not the time
this bowl is see-through you know i'm
really uncomfortable right now
and i don't have eyelids so this is all
on you atrey tochuwana are pretty rare
and not completely understood
though it looks like a snake it's more
biologically related to an earthworm or
maybe another lungless amphibian like a
salamander
researchers are still i think we should
move on agreed
goliath birdie the spy holy sh
sometimes the name says it all the
goliath bird eater
is the largest spider in the world and
it's called bird eater because an 18th
century naturalist discovered one
devouring a hummingbird now it rarely
eats birds but it's only because it
can't catch them
it usually eats worms or large insects
but it will gladly eat mice lizards even
snakes if it can catch them
oh like other tarantulas it features
fangs and venom
of course it does there are lots of
videos online showing a goliath spider
eating its prey i will link some of
those below
but be warned it is not for the faint of
heart
it's it's awful watching a goliath feed
in captivity is usually the only way to
see it eat
in the wild it prefers to dine in
private first it
catches its prey and then sticks the
fangs in and stuns them or kills them
then it drags the carcass back to its
burrow and
liquefies its insides and sucks them dry
yum the food chain works both ways
though
in parts of south america the goliath is
part of the local cuisine
they're typically wrapped in banana
leaves and then roasted over a fire
people on the internet say they taste
like shrimp i'll take their word for it
human butt fly no buildup here i'm
telling you right up front
bot fly larva are terror maggots that
grow
and feed on human flesh i'm going to
show you this
you have been warned there are several
kinds of bot flies that infect mammals
but they're typically associated with
large
grazing mammals like horses or steer but
there are bot flies that infect humans
and they use mosquitoes as a carrier a
female bot fly bites a mosquito
then the mosquito bites you and your
body heat then triggers the eggs to
hatch
then they grow into larvae that burrow
into the wound
it gets worse the larvae then grow and
they use your
puncture your wound hole to
um poop and when the bob fly is exposed
aka pooping you can tweeze it out
but the larva are covered in tiny little
spikes that anchor it into the flesh
which makes removal at this
time kind of painful another option is
just waiting three short months then it
will grow big enough to just wiggle its
way out on its own
no big deal could you wait three months
i could barely get through three seconds
of watching these videos
speaking of there are lots of botfly
removal videos
on youtube like way too many i will link
to some of the
more gross ones below because i know
some of you are into watching
stuff like that i don't know why seek
help but here's a life lesson let's say
it's your wedding day and you've got
a swollen oozy push tool you might
want to have a doctor take a look at
that
you could be the unwitting surrogate
mother of the hellish flesh-eating
terror maggot
known as the human body
happy anniversary honey
thank you so much for hanging out with
us today my name is aj
that's hecklefish this has been the
y-files today we talked about the 10
most terrifying animals that actually
exist
what animals did we miss put them in the
comments section so everyone can check
them out we had fun creating this video
for you if you had fun watching please
hit the like button it really helps out
the channel if you just found us please
consider subscribing if we didn't earn
your subscription today i promise we'll
keep making
brainy content until we do earn it until
next time be safe be kind and know that
you
are appreciated
you look like brian seacrest with a
hangover you look like a one-man boy
band still chasing a dream
you look like a one-man boy band with
the instagram old filter
i could do this all day